[Musica]
[Applauso]
cosa succede nel nostro cervello quando
percepiamo uno stimolo esterno non è
facile dare una risposta a questa
domanda ma ci possiamo provare facendoci
aiutare dalla neurobiologia il nostro
cervello è costituito da circa 100
miliardi di neuroni che tra loro sono
connessi mediamente con 10 mila
connessioni appunto per un numero
complessivo davvero esorbitante un
milione di miliardi
ogni qualvolta noi percepiamo uno
stimolo esterno queste connessioni
cercano di dare un significato questo
stimolo e ogni qualvolta questo
significato che noi diamo a successo
noi lavoriamo in una routine che
richiamiamo ogni qual volta ci troviamo
di fronte a una situazione analoga
facciamo un esempio molto semplice tutti
noi riconosciamo essere questa è una
lettera è un numero 5
ma c'è stato un momento particolare
nella nostra vita in cui per la prima
volta abbiamo appreso che quel segno era
una e quell'altro segno era un numero 5
e ogni qual volta ci troviamo di fronte
a qualcosa di simile lo riportiamo
immediatamente alla lettera al numero 5
questo significa che le nostre strutture
cognitive i nostri neuroni si
riposizionano nel dare questo tipo di
significato quindi c'è una dimensione
neuronale e una cognitiva quindi una
disposizione biologica dell'unione dei
neuroni la cito architettonica cioè il
modo in cui tutti i neuroni si
predispongono nel nostro cervello e il
significato cognitivo che noi diamo a
questi con un condizionamento reciproco
ma cosa succede quando ci troviamo di
fronte a un simbolo che invece può avere
più di un significato ha un significato
ambiguo che cos'è questo può essere un
hashtag può essere un diesis può essere
il gioco descrisse il cancelletto che il
telefono eccetera può avere diversi
significati se non c'è un contesto ben
definito
rimane appunto indefinito ma la domanda
è perché noi diamo un significato
preciso perché proprio quello e non un
altro
la risposta è abbastanza banale il primo
significato che ci viene in mente è
quello che c'è più familiare a mia madre
non verrebbe mai in mente il concetto di
hashtag a mia nonna non sarebbe venuto
mai in mente il concetto di cancelletto
del telefono a un ragazzo della mia
generazione invece sarebbe venuto in
mente immediatamente dopo del tris
quindi tutto ciò che familiare noi lo
riportiamo a quanto dice ho conosciuto
perché il nostro cervello e conservatore
da questo punto di vista cerca di
adattare il nuovo a quanto già possiede
facciamo adesso
un esempio musicale provate ad ascoltare
questo frammento grazie bene l'abbiamo
riconosciuto tutti
e l'incipit della piccola serenata
notturna di bozze a tutti noi risulta
familiare gradevole piacevole perché lo
riconosciamo immediatamente perché lo
troviamo così familiare gradevole
guardiamo un attimo la partitura
guardate nelle prime otto note noi
troviamo quattro volte la stessa nota
che si ripete questa nota e una nota
particolare si chiama tonica e quella
che il nostro cervello cerca per
ancorarsi per appoggiarsi appena
l'abbiamo ascoltato il nostro cervello
andava alla ricerca proprio di quel
appoggio perché in effetti
dovete sapere che ogni singolo suono se
noi lo in uk le assi ogni singola nota è
composta da un universo sonora enorme
potremmo dire quasi infinito guardate
questa sequenza questa è la sequenza
degli armonici praticamente i micro
suoni che compongono ogni singolo suono
ogni singolo suono che loro adesso hanno
realizzato era costituito dall'insieme
di tutti questi micro suoni e i primi
quattro tra i primi otto come vedete ce
ne sono quattro
che anche se hanno altezze diverse sono
lo stesso suono che normanna che in
questo caso il dopo che danno il nome
alle varie note in questo caso sono gli
armonici del do se avessimo avuto quelli
del mio avremmo trovato quattro mia
all'inizio 4 sola e così via
quindi la nostra capacità percettiva
riconosce immediatamente quello che è
prevalente in questo caso i primi suoni
su 8.4 che si ripropongono sono quelli
fondamentali è qualcosa che
acusticamente esiste in natura e che è
diventata per noi una base culturale
siamo immersi in un universo sonoro che
si basa su queste strutture che sono
alla base dell'armonia quella che
abbiamo appena sentito in mozart per la
piccola serenata notturna
ecco perché il nostro orecchio il nostro
cervello li riconosce come familiari
gradevoli appunto e ogni qualvolta
appunto noi
riproduciamo questi suoni dovete tenere
conto che rispondono a quelle strutture
armoniche che i compositori cercano di
mettere in atto quando realizzano le
loro opere
ascoltiamo adesso un altro breve brano
leggermente più lungo rispetto a quello
che abbiamo sentito prima
credo sconosciuto ai più e vediamo cosa
succede questa volta nel nostro cervello
prego
[Musica]
grazie cosa succede questa volta quanto
siamo lontani dai canoni musicali del
settecento in che epoca siamo chi può
essere l'autore forse noi oggi lo
apprezziamo questo brano meraviglioso ma
quando fu eseguito la prima volta la
sera del 12 febbraio del 1785 lo
sconcerto fu enorme e anche nelle
esecuzioni successive si gridava allo
scandalo queste note che scrivevano
queste dissonanze nessuno riuscì ad
apprezzare la grandezza di mozart
questo brano che abbiamo appena
ascoltato e di wolfgang amadeus mozart
un genio che in un colpo solo era
arrivato in una musica che si esprime
con un linguaggio tipico del novecento
il rifiuto assoluto
c'erano proteste c'era chi portava
indietro la partitura per chiedere di
correggere gli errori
c'era chi parlava di orecchio guasto da
parte di mozart
tutti tranne una persona che quella sera
era presente all'esecuzione franz joseph
haydn grandissimo musicista che così si
espresse alla presenza del padre di
mozart via fermo davanti a dio e come
persona onesta che vostro figlio il più
grande compositore che io conosca di
persona o per sentito dire a del gusto e
inoltre la più grande scienza della
musica
cogliendo nell'immensa grandezza ma
perché proprio hiding e perché gli altri
invece ebbero un moto di rifiuto nei
confronti di questa composizione che ci
appare così diversa così poco familiare
rispetto all'altra guardate il motivo è
legato al fatto che in realtà il genio è
qualcosa di estremamente complesso chi è
mozart
cosa sappiamo noi di lui certo abbiamo
tutta la sua musica milioni di note
codificate ma chi era realmente mozart
in cosa consiste concretamente il suo
genio
ciò che è stato sottoposto una
disciplina ferrea che è cresciuta in un
ambiente particolare e che ha prodotto
comunque una musica sublime guardiamo un
attimo di nuovo la sequenza degli
armonici anziché soffermarci sui primi
andiamo sui micro suoni più lontani
guardate note che stridono molto vicine
tra di loro e potremmo continuare fino a
trovare i quarti di tono e così via
bene la grandezza la grande sensibilità
artistica del musicista sta proprio in
questo non riuscirà a cogliere questi
rapporti più lontani su cui ha
strutturato poi l'armonia della musica
successiva quindi lui riusciva a sentire
accogliere a percepire degli elementi
sconosciuti ai più
ci sono molti decenni dopo riuscivano a
cogliere potremmo dire semplificando al
massimo che tutta la storia della musica
è una costante emancipazione verso la
dissonanza così come è stato anche per
la storia dell'arte è certamente molto
strana non a caso isolato
esempi analoghi li avremmo potuto fare
con moltissimi altri musicisti e artisti
ma allora tutto si evolve grazie allo
spirito di alcuni pionieri che sono
costretti poi con sconforto guardare al
futuro
come scritto un grandissimo autore
americano e inevitabilmente sconfortante
guardare attraverso noi occhi cose alle
quali abbiamo già applicato la nostra
visuale e quindi crea uno iato
profondissimo tra l'autore e il il
pubblico oppure tutto si evolve verso
qualcosa di migliore non è esattamente
così prendiamo un esempio dalla
tecnologia tutti riconosciamo la
tastiera del computer ma vi siete mai
chiesti perché la disposizione dei tasti
è questa e non un'altra perché abbiamo
la pula w la eccetera si dice tastiera
qwerty e non c'è un altro a disposizione
anche in questo caso la risposta è
banale perché fu la prima a disposizione
dei tasti che venne introdotta quando
nacque la macchina per scrivere nei
decenni successivi furono sviluppate
delle altre tasti
ergonomicamente più efficaci ma non
riuscirono a imporsi sul mercato perché
tutti richiedevano le tastiere qwerty
perché avevano imparato ad usarle perché
il cervello come dicevo prima tende a
riportare a quello che già conosce gli
elementi nuovi e quindi abbiamo avuto
una rigidità che si è manifestata e
molti altri elementi della nostra
tecnologia che di fatto non ha
selezionato ha fatto le tecnologie
migliori ma consideriamo il nostro dna
per capire esattamente che cosa succede
nei processi di innovazione nel processo
di ri applique di replicazione ogni
miliardo di pio ii nuovi sede crea uno
per errore
alcuni di questi errori funzionano
creano delle novità e determinano un
innovazione un cambiamento quindi di
fatto se noi mettiamo insieme questi tre
elementi la biologia che vale a dire il
i geni che ciascuno di noi ha il
patrimonio genetico
l'esperienza e nel caso di mozart
appunto l'esercizio importante e un
terzo fattore l'ambiente vale a dire un
ambiente che sia stimolante che non sia
ripetitivo e basato solo sulla routine
abbiamo i tre elementi fondamentali che
costituiscono la creatività umana
adriano olivetti intuì quanto questo
fosse importante e mise a lavorare gli
uni accanto agli altri operai con
ingegneri artisti e filosofi tutti
insieme perché sono dal cui a cervo di
queste diverse esperienze potevano
emergere i sentieri giusti per portare
alla progettazione delle macchine
pensanti il computer e teniamo bene in
considerazione questa lezione
fondamentale
teniamo in considerazione quanto sia
importante mettere sempre insieme questi
elementi per sviluppare in tutti i
livelli formativi la creatività umana
perché se come esseri umani siamo
caratterizzati da tanti limiti
computazionali cognitivi mnemonici
sappiamo risolvere problemi estremamente
complessi e ci sappiamo esprimere
attraverso il sublime linguaggio
dell'arte sottomessi come siamo
all'attenzione e risolta tra mente e
cervello
remiamo barche controcorrente risospinti
senza sosta nel passato grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]